[Musik]
halt zusammen heute machen wir ein
apfelkuchen rezept ich habe schon ein
paar apfelkuchen der zirkel die sind
auch alle job gesetz aber heute habe ich
mir überlegt wir machen einen
apfelkuchen auch ein blech also mehr so
die eckige variante und auch sehr saftig
und trotzdem schnell ich würde mal
schätzen
realistisch gesehen in 30 minuten mit
allem drum und dran ab regen stehen und
und und ist der im backofen und ja keine
arbeit mehr
ok ok 26 okay
14 der 26 aber wir drehen auch egal
herausforderungen angenommen
ich schaffe das ditzingen mache jetzt
direkt die nächste kamera hier an der
seite an ich will nämlich direkt los ich
fange an mit dem topping quasi mit dem
streuseln kamera läuft
ok ich nehme jetzt erstmal flüssige
butter ist sowieso bereich flüssig wie
vor so dass man es gut verrühren kann
und gibt ihm eine schüssel
ich habe ich übrigens alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben wohin am sarg in dem sie
genau mein gott da gebe ich jetzt noch
mehr dazu und zucker und vanille extrakt
und ich gebe auch zimt dazu das ist
nämlich für nicht so typisch eine
typische apfel kombination vanille und
zimt
fast immer wenn wir schon den zutaten
sind das kann ich auch schon direkt die
haselnüsse dazu geben dann habe ich
alles so jetzt habe ich mir ein bisschen
zeit verschafft weil sie schnell war und
jetzt kann ich in aller ruhe geben
[Musik]
also das sind jetzt die fertigen
streusel die brauchen wir gleich erst
wieder und ich kümmere mich jetzt um die
äpfel du machst mir den druck hier jetzt
bin wenn wir uns jetzt in change gesetzt
dann will ich die auch meistern so
scheele
ja es ist jetzt kein spektakulärer
schritt den kann ich einfach mal machen
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich die äpfel in kleine
stücke geschnitten
ich hab die schale vorher entfernt weil
ich mag das nicht so also das hat kein
schönes mundgefühl wie ich finde
und ich glaube ich bin auch die einzige
ob wunsches hauptberuflich machen die
keinen wie heißt noch mal wenn du die
die kerne vom apfel rausholt und kerner
die einzige was nicht hart anhört hast
du ich mich aber ich brauchte ich das
nie und deswegen besitze ich kann also
immer besitzt eine citrus presse dies
nämlich mega praktisch und da werde ich
jetzt ein bisschen zitrone darüber
träufeln lassen damit es auch später
nicht braun wird solange ich es ziemlich
den restlichen teig vorbereitet
[Musik]
nach frühstück ist eingefallen wurde es
jetzt auch ein bisschen zucker dazu tun
gut umrühren und dann geht's weiter mit
dem teig soll die streusel haben wir die
äpfel haben wir also die füllung quasi
und jetzt brauchen wir auch einen boden
das soll ein sehr saftiger und fluffige
boden sein
ich werde aber die eier nicht trennen
sondern die saftigkeit hole ich mir
jetzt aus butter und butter gebe ich
jetzt im zimmer war zustand in die
rührschüssel da gebe ich zucker mit dazu
und auch vanille extrakt gerne auch
schon zimt und wenn ihr kein zimmer und
den kennt übrigens auch komplett
weglassen und dann ruhig das ganze auf
höchster geschwindigkeit circa fünf
minuten wuchs auf die uhr so oft das
heißt die minuten habe ich mach dich
locker locker
[Musik]
so jetzt kommen nach und nach die eier
dazu bei niedriger stufe schön einrühren
[Musik]
so mehl und backpulver noch dazu sieben
und nur ganz kurz einrühren und
anschließend das ganze noch mal mit
etwas milch vermischen und dann solltet
ihr einen schönen tag erhalten der in
etwa so aussieht wieso muffin teig so
ein bisschen und dann habe ich jeweils
vorbereitet das zeige ich euch ich habe
hier ein backblech das ist komplett
gerade das ist mein ehemaliges backblech
das werde ich euch in die infobox
verlinken sodann habe ich jemandem back
rahmen den habe ich auf 25 x 25 cm
eingestellt und da werde ich jetzt
einfach mal den teig reingeben haben so
sieht's aus mit der zeit
jetzt kommt ja auch gleich den ofen das
heißt leute in der halbe stunde trotz
drehen werde es auch schaffen so die
äpfel gebe ich jetzt direkt auf den teig
und nach möglichkeit die flüssigkeit die
hier noch drin hängt nicht unbedingt
jetzt mit dazutun jetzt sehe ich auch so
ein bisschen verteilen und dann kommt
die streusel dazu
[Musik]
ich freue mich schon wenn ich habe extra
alles liegen lassen wenn haben sich
alles schön aufräumen ist nochmal ein
stückchen dann lege ich mich hin und du
kannst den rest machen wir haben fünf zu
übersehen
und wir das ist eigentlich wie wo was
gerade gemacht
wie gemein ganz
das ist so da und nicht gerade so dauern
ok ich sage euch jetzt schon die
backzeit 180 grad ober unterhitze bitte
unbedingt vorheizen den backofen und den
bug den so ungefähr 35 bis maximal 40
minuten aber wir können auch gucken ob
die sträuße schön gold
[Musik]
bei mir hat es noch 35 minuten gedauert
und der ist noch so lauf war ich möchte
ihnen meine lauwarm probieren erwarten
bis der abkühlt oder habe schon gar
keine geduld wenn ich ehrlich bin
überhaupt nicht wir sagt man das schon
immer erst dann süß es muss einmal hier
unterziehen
so und jetzt finde ich ihn mir meinen
backform löser damit ich mir die seiten
ins auch nicht weg reiße jeder einmal an
den seiten entlang
das mache ich nicht all das macht der
backform reza toll
doch was das ist ja heftig nein das ist
echt toll verlinke ich euch natürlich in
den info box so und jetzt habe ich ein
paar geworden heisst horn
das heißt wir heute so krise drauf sind
so habe ich einen plan a perfect jetzt
nehme ich mir meine ekm einen eckigen
torten retter und jeder einmal und
darunter dann habe ich auch direkt eine
unterlage dafür ja entschuldigung
es macht ja sonst keine werbung
[Musik]
perfekt das probieren wir haben sagt mit
dir zusammen so hamza du darfst ja mit
mir zusammen probieren ja auch schon
wieder seit so mache ich noch
puderzucker obendrauf als krönenden
abschluss ein hase ein ok wollen wir
nicht ungeduldig egal wo fotografien
dass man fährt endlich das ist schon so
ein bisschen davon ja so ein stückchen
java user okay jetzt probieren wir
zusammen waren so wir probieren und dann
zeigt nur unsere mimik wie wir den
geschmack finden
ok muss in die kamera und und dynamic
sprechen lassen dann gucke ich das
wirklich
also drin 123
weil sie das merkt kennst du das im
winter ist ja mal april und 10
wir sind es ist einfach ein kuschel ja
und was absolut kuchen essen
naja ich richtig ich fühle dass ich
richtig gut also dass und laura und
schmeckt ja auch geil gleichermaßen weiß
was ich auch nicht mag wenn wir auf dem
kuchen oder zug hat und jetzt nicht über
zu können ja der ist nicht zu süßen aber
auch nicht zu wenig gedacht er ist auch
perfekt leute der ist perfekt macht
demnach nachher genau woche bis heute ja
stimmt das errechnete irgendwas hab ich
das doch erinnert so ein bisschen man
apple terrorisieren
kannst du dich man merkt ich habe sehr
sehr viel erfahrung in diesem bereich
aufgegriffen
richtig lecker unbedingt das wäre es
auch machen danach machen dann machen
abonnieren sie einen kanal falls jetzt
noch nicht gemacht habt und dann würde
ich mal sagen hansa beim nächsten mal
sehen wir uns dann wieder und dann bin
ich dafür dass die öfter mal vor der
kamera probierst ja ich war schon jetzt
ist klar ist aber auch instagram folgen
dann ist alles an als kamera schon soll
ich mir also bis zum nächsten mal auf
welches kitchen jack's risiken und der
hansa jet set mit z nicht mit sondern
mit mütze
das war's machen es komm raus ich mach
das jetzt
[Musik]